Joe Joe Joe Barton
Bartnik what's our full podcast word so
full podcast
what's our full podcast ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the what's our full
podcast and I remind you what podcast it
is we are not live on youtube today
yeah technical difficulties but we're
here man we'll have video up this
evening this evening gonna be up if you
listening same time as you're watching
it right now happy holidays everybody
tis the season to be jolly
fa-la-la-la-la would eat we got Rodrigo
Torres Rizzo and Lisa do you think he'll
get through these cameras new movie it's
a short film and TV shows up
and what's upper body man yeah we play
the Christmas tree up in Halloween
Halloween right yeah
Filipino Christmas Filipino Christmas
they start putting your own right
no no you're right so September it's all
the burn month September October
November other Berman's yeah the month
so September starts like getting us at
embryos it's a Catholic thing it's a
Catholic oh yeah but the trees not
Catholic
trees in Manoa the trees pagan jungle
trees I don't know there's a lemon tree
bro but Nana to put a little cactus bro
haha trailer and swampy over the road I
think so yeah mosquito land Oh bamboo
tree having to you have it yeah seen a
nurse like a red barber with a little
Christmas tree on a little nurses what's
up I know a lot of people out there who
listen to a podcast saw that there was a
fan that got up he got up you know you
got beat up by the police officers Oh
instead of jail but this direction of
expression officers this guy was like
one of those people that doesn't really
like pose that many pose
yeah but his last pose let's - eats
before two weeks before he saw me a NAPA
he's a fan of the show find out a comedy
I sold him a shirt he was at my show but
then now I get two weeks later something
crazy happened and he got beat up by
correctional officers yeah but people
who saw the that he got beat up saw that
when I that the last polar before that
were with me yeah same jacket on you
jacket on let's say you find them he
boys people assumed that path to my show
and then we assumed that we were hanging
out bro dog [ __ ] you right down on I
heart I think
they pulled the last photo before his
beatdown photo they Felipe and him
shaking hands and that was the leading
photo and then all these people you
should do something Felipe man we shared
it a bunch of people with like a million
followers shared it and and then the
people like who don't aren't even
following me they don't even know who I
am you know they just saw me in a photo
and man your best friend up
happen right after you show what are you
gonna do you don't care about your fans
yeah well you don't want people get beat
up after iron maiden concert yeah man
with a left but then well the last time
people went after the Raiders owner
broker you got beat up by Raiders
football party never man although
there's a hashtag in the ordinary man
the horrible haircut Oh Dave hey Chucky
what's up fool man I remember this
crazy-ass Christmas dude when I was a
little boy we were living in now we were
living on glass street across history
from Pete Campari and my mom was always
involved bro like like she knew it shut
the connection like it remember the free
lunch she'll know that they they give
free lunch at midnight and over that
this part to give it at 10:00 so we're
here to both parties yeah a Baptist
Church about my house like I'm not even
a block away when I was living before we
moved to the projects it was like [ __ ]
it was five of us living in a
one-bedroom now you do it so I've done
that bro brother no it was and it was
man with little dude with little kids
but you don't know how small it is
proven in the arrow and we heard are not
gonna door right
I say what stuff are you my dad 102 tone
answered or papillary money cuz it was a
police dog
why then one thousand underwear we
watching TV brother we watch TV
come here at the right place to look too
but he was sparse of residence parcel
get you go sister blaming me though how
were you Oh anyway with ice don't take
it all the way
yeah papers so you can have friends
brother deliver our building so it was
the police brought it brought a box full
of toys
oh that's cool a program that their APD
had any still have it Navidad and barrio
so they're going to or the door to the
[ __ ] of families do you know what
that's for they gave us two writers out
there for like you crime goes down you
can call let us know what's going on
here here's a couple toys for you send
you a couple alters from one trying to
get people to not the bar the box had a
[ __ ] turkey with code frozen and I
got other nickname you need for Turkey
and a bunch of toys bro like unwrapped
toys hello
it was right for us it was old toys but
for everybody it was that it continued
nasty ass boy nobody why it was the
whole cast of that show welcome back
harder and the guy you open up for gay
Kaplan yeah yeah the first time ever
open he was awesome we went to uh yes
stories and he doesn't talk to anybody
afterwards or whatever but he was a
really nice guy I took him he took me to
Denny's and then I took him to a to a
topless bar Here I am in a topless bar
look well actually was nude bar and I'm
get for yeah we're looking at these
naked chicks I'm welcome back Carter
right here man I'm like holy cow boners
watching that kick that guy here welcome
back
he's not telling me which one do you
want he's a poker player right yeah
big-time professional poker player yeah
yeah but what do they do now I don't
know man I don't need yeah I haven't
heard the last time I work with them oh
man it was quite twenty years ago oh
damn yeah so I mean yes he's alive hey
when you start it off when you turn it
off stand up I know it's not somebody
before but you never open how you never
open mic you just went at it no no I did
open mic I did open mic for a couple of
times yo Arizona and I thought you just
went to let Bowl Blackwood show that
with your props and went on stage no no
I did I did possibly once cuz I tried
everything you know everything bro hey
you punk I used to wear I did an
impression of shark feed man no no no it
was Bronson G Charles Robinson his
sister Charlene and I would sock right
huh the sock no no I had a I put on a
wig with ponytails yeah and I just made
a face like Charles Bronson and
everybody loved it and if stupid man but
they worked you plug you in the dance
James Coburn is standing over there
don't one of the problem right no no I
had another thing too I had some
Christmas ornament thing I don't know I
tried to call Oliver what w hosted I
wrote a Latino night uh-huh oh that I
probably member stevea state house or
somewhere eating you know [ __ ]
[Laughter]
ten characters action guy no no no
warranty the construction guy no you
know there was I think it was when I was
auditioning for MADtv oh I went up when
they think that no I think was the laugh
actor he believed it or not and I went
up there and I did a bunch of characters
and I don't remember what they were but
I did a bunch of Kerik one guy was
reverend grass back i was like a
preacher and i had this plant coming out
of my back that was before everybody
will do it sketches bro it was on Def
Jam Bible where Peter put it at that oh
no it's def gospel death gospel Comedy
Jam yeah basically it was like they were
doing like religious material but a
[ __ ]
45 minutes of stand-up they doing those
sketches at the warehouse along with the
word the Rudy moran no1 it was widely
distributed but Ford didn't do it yeah
poor wanted to keep all the money you
know they were gonna give me a shitty
deal and then they don't want any
sketches and I'm like no no I want the
sketch because the sketches are gonna be
there won't be time be there always will
brother flip on the radio yeah and I
still make you know you sound exchange I
still make money on the sketches more
than the standard what year was that
ninety six seven eight
yes windows I see this like ninety nine
but was with the Latino another sketch
bro you had about it was the a boxing
guy no I don't I think it was it may be
the race track the race track yeah
that's what it was it was like soccer
sucker come down the road with uh
followed by snappers
but Parliament's big snapper yes it was
just all [ __ ] dirty name fellatio
coming around like it was just all dirty
names and everything it was [ __ ]
followed by uppity ass one day I think
the winner was like [ __ ] by a head
or something like that it was just but
you know I had all the sound effects and
everything in this and I made all of
those things on reel-to-reel wasn't even
digital back then so I had reel-to-reel
and I was using it because I worked
rewind stop yeah you have to lay it lead
layers of you know the sound effects and
all that stuff that's it that's it yeah
I did all that stuff back hard but it
was fun and it would those things still
work you know it was a deeper seeing
Olympics it was like it was basically
was like like an Olympic event was like
alright you here we go from Switzerland
we've got so-and-so yeah if someone was
known for have a dirty mouth it was like
and then they would just curse like
everyday pop come [ __ ]
[ __ ] like oh boy he missed out
on the door it was just like an Olympic
event but you know what all Kersey so
just cursing Olympics it's just stupid
[ __ ] you still have that available or
digitally or anywhere I would probably
have to look funny [ __ ] that homeboy
what's his name anymore
know that food from the Orange County
don't wanna read the George Lopez base
happy a DJ happy Luna or the guy Junie
Jumba you know you gather an Armenian
sidekick tisha Tasha
Omar me Yanni he did one of George Lopez
bits into oh yeah oh you mean J
Valentino so what he does he is pretty
much like that show
what's it called we're like like Toby
hick show ya where they show like the
low plates and a bit and after that I
have people acting out the bits the bits
yeah so yeah I could do something like
that you know yeah I reckon to 2020 yeah
and they goes to a two-minute hit right
away yeah do his videos
it's always fascinates me you know I'll
do something I'll put a lot of
production behind it you know get it
give me a thousand hits somebody else
does and you know just something dumb or
whatever I'm not saying that something's
probably it sounds great actually but
somebody else is saying somebody
somebody you say something dumb or do
something wrong and they get all these
Carmen has a million likes but there are
videos do the same things you think
should go viral don't and then yeah we
put up one thing on your page one time
years ago look remember it was the
concert concert it was a quiet guy that
Harry read Harry and when people throw
the cat when you're that moment when
your homies arm looks like a cat or
something and then it went viral and
because everybody over in like Holland
and Germany they start sharing in the
media we woke up and it was like a
million people had seen it was crazy I
was like this stupid thing right it's
true looks like the people who are
millionaires now and all they do is show
videos of them playing videos yeah like
what did we choose like that god bless
them but I'm like it's the kids poorly
watching baseball yeah dude and all the
little kids have devices dude who are
you comedy influences Joey oh yeah
that's it there's a little Amazon below
the belts on Amazon my comedy influences
like when I was a kid it was obviously
was Eddie Murphy which it was Brett Fox
it was Richard Pryor George Carlin I
would listen to all those guys I was
listen to albums the vinyl back then you
know I mean yeah but I won't listen to
other things like how I got the idea for
the sketches my theme was I listened to
an album called
that's not funny that's sick from
National Lampoon and it was just
sketches and it was a lot of the people
who weren't setting that live at the
time were yeah I think they did that and
it was [ __ ] hilarious if you watch
the document are not documentary but the
more
the narrative it's it's got a long title
stupid it's a long time I'll find it but
it's about the guy Doug Kenny Kenny Shea
he's that guy in out of my house called
mothball no it's um because all those
like even like before the inception of
TV they had radio and they used to you
know act it all out on radio shows and
they were really creative like I don't
sad oh I'm sorry it's called a futile
and stupid gesture and they sketches
that they were the SNL people were doing
yeah because it was really hilarious one
there's a bunch on there there's one
where where someone's imitating they're
doing a parody of Mister Rogers
neighborhood and the guys like you know
this guy comes in he goes yeah hi I'm
Bob it was yes you're Timmy's dad yeah I
want to talk to you about my son Timmy
he says you touched him last Tuesday and
as the whole thing goes yeah he's he's
got a special job to feed the fish about
orange juice that had me dying laughing
like it's just really funny sketches so
anyway I've always loved that because I
love that when I finally had you know
got to do my own CD I decided to put the
sketches in there yeah nobody does
sketches anymore it was like Cheech and
Chong like Sandler did some Joe Rogan
had some on his album but like other
people don't really do it and then
rapper started doing sketch the rappers
would drop some in we're like scruncho
and like alright
dog and dr. Dre started throwing in
sketches and it was just creative and me
wasn't to which one the one we got man
whatever that my iPhone oh wow tree has
equipment that we made were all bad for
you
75 $55 $55 that let you set it like that
our late buddy no she's a naughty Dog
painting oh no oh I got a paper plane
ticket that mean I don't have you know
mom another kitchen there with boy and
I'm just catching hours ago what what's
up baby what's the what are you doing
how come your voice are now different or
[ __ ] come on oh man whose car is in the
front
whose cars is in the front Oh mom you
still have that [ __ ] rental I tell
you take that [ __ ] back oh that's my
mild shipping hold on man cut up let's
get you sir which is a cool because
they're easier to do but they're it's
exactly shooting a video except it's
just all you're doing is writing in and
performing it on a mic instead of doing
it on camera but it's exactly the same
thing sometimes I guess my musicians
believe but you want to do a sketch on
my on my album but I said William but
the really tell you I'm gonna write do
all the work you write this case bro I
feel like a lab let's collab you no no
no okay let's collab and help me move
this week yeah you bring you bring the
pickup truck and I'll bring the pizza
let's collab row I have a barbecue bring
the me brewer grill plates let's collab
you were my ugly shirt that I made in my
garage
fool man so we're getting back man so
though the police showed up any brother
presence and they by lobby both
presidents because my mom got the
hookups oh he was talking about the free
presents that cops were passing out
no no nah be that it bother those NYPD
cop probably taking that [ __ ] cell Oh
New York New York City during the summer
we would have a free lunch there would
be like trucks that came by truck has
trays with food in it they had like like
like a bologna sandwich
a little juice and a banana and you know
in a like Forks in that little plastic
forks and knives but the funny thing is
I don't know how my grandmother used to
do it she would come home with shopping
bags of those trays so you open up there
with the refrigerator of my house and we
just had those gee dude they were just
all there so we were just like that's
breakfast lunch and dinner that's what
we had like your mom her refrigerator
when she worked doing that after school
she would come along she would have them
all those little enchiladas between all
the coffee cakes they had the peanut
butter I know the microwave room was
smashed woman there's a lot of merchants
that house a creative man you gotta feed
your kid you look out what to do exactly
either nasty [ __ ] though that's the one
I have best played like are the one that
little vegetable or fruit I'll [ __ ] down
there I like don't have anymore like I
know they have frozen food but I guess I
don't have married I don't with the foil
on it the old TV dinners with the
chicken the best ones for me was at one
with the two pieces of chicken
my dad would let us take the little meal
you know I have to pick it by the
[ __ ] desert
yeah
exactly in my opinion chocolate huh I
like the meatloaf bro do the meatloaf
sandwich dog oh that's very steak if
you're an idiot you burned yourself
trying to pick it up yeah because one
cooks faster than the others so it's
like you're supposed to here doesn't
match up you know you get it's funny huh
whenever we ate that I never asked for
more like I probably was enough yeah a
complete balance you know what ii like
the word seconds was white friends you
know I go coat ribs and I would be
jealous of my friends that I like the
Lunchables the small ones and I was like
a big bag of like food i'd be like i
wonned up but there is still [ __ ]
hungry after that shitty reason the bag
was actually empty one the Wonder Bread
bag you ever put your sandwich what you
know I watch it watching those
commercials to watch those commercial be
like for frost you've played up a
balanced meal yeah there we sure bowl of
cereal toast and toes I have never I
will get the boy we're just sitting on
the couch eating cereal you want toast
or cereal Sweden and they don't eat
cereal in the morning bro and the box of
frosted flakes cost 20 bucks pastries
you can't eat that sorry
yeah you can't buy cereal over there she
says it's like a store that specializes
in like American things and they've
shown the boxes eight healthy over there
I know
yeah the premium I walk around and
really love you up in the gym is like
that like Hot Cheetos and takis and
stuff those are banned over there he
went to France and I guess it's an
insult if you give somebody like it sure
a large shirt put that [ __ ] over my neck
I know three medium yes what happened
look good you look like my well I loves
me I lost too close to 30 pounds no you
look
ya know I right now I lost 30 pounds
close to 30 pounds anymore back then no
I was heavy but I was in yeah drinking a
lot you know free alcohol it's got a
good it was it left him bout or the one
you to lose weight no it's like a girl
brittle because they'd met guys that
worked it yeah it was like to move the
little hooks they're over there pretty
longer though the real putting on makeup
yeah reading bikes on stage that's not
gonna burn about Tina talks yeah yeah no
no but it's good like read it man cause
I wanted to look good on TV or not TV
big right huge it was actually in
theaters so there's still two comedians
walking around regretting the day wait
that must be like over like 20 years ago
no not talking to no I wish but it'll
never happen you Lopez
George Lopez doesn't care about any of
that anymore
[Laughter]
no no just I was the user will he was on
Latin Palooza
no that was Latin Kings of Campos Rios
was like yeah part of you have told me
that winner won it points
yeah yes you toasted right you and Alex
would have first and then then Paul
closed it New Mexico
no we shot that no Passover yeah looks
good and it was in theaters so like I
literally at when it was in theaters I
would put the stage George Lopez yeah at
the end at the end I think no I'd
enjoyed Paul did Paul lowrider song yeah
yeah instead of George yeah you have was
in the beginning and then it was
actually in the hold the beginning of
the movie was was that but it was cool
because like I would go to a city do
stand-up and then at the end I would
catch the last airing of the movie like
you know Latin Kings of Comedy and I
would sit in the back you know watch
people watching like this looking for a
spot on TV dog go through the mall with
the wearing the same [ __ ] the next day
[Laughter]
so you can see dressed like a penguin
out there happy
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it's a road by yourself like don't
have to [ __ ] it or with anybody
yeah and I knew I was gonna happen I
mean because I you know I I know I just
knew it because you know Kingdom the
Kings of Comedy came out before that
obviously right and then Paramount
Pictures came to the shooting of this is
when we shot it it wasn't scheduled we
didn't even have a name yet so I didn't
had a distributor yet no paramount so
paramount came to the shooting and
because they liked what they saw they
decided to make it part of the same you
know the same franchises universe yeah
so with that that's what lucked out and
if it wasn't for that it wouldn't would
have never happened
who came up with that Paul did you have
to pay to a Latin comedy guy and money
with yeah the name Walter Latham I guess
they license there anything that was
Keynes of common harm what were too late
them yet so they're all of piece of
company yeah but see they cholo slam
yeah the King I did shallow slam and I
also did Latin Palooza Willie Barcena
Darren Carter
Olivia mundo he brought the motorcycle
on stage yeah yeah and Mike Robles was
on that that was on Alex theater right
yeah Alex either we shot that was the
first comedy show ever shot now come on
Toya yeah it was it was probably about
$100,000
out of your mind reduction I don't know
what I did was this is this is how I let
blues happened during that time was
laughable Musa with Jamie Foxx Jamie
Foxx right and it was on all the DVD
shelves Palooza know all right so so
what I did was I found out who produced
her who was the distributor which was at
the time Image Entertainment
so I found them out I hate I said a
meeting up with them and hell listen I'm
gonna I want to do a comedy special and
it'll be right on the shelf next to
laugh of loser cuz it laughs loose it
was doing well it was okay what is he I
go to Latin put loser he goes okay I
want it that was a nice yes I bought it
so so that body
just with that saying it's going to be
on the shelf McQuaid the distributor
readies it done laughs Appaloosa that's
it that easy and then and then what they
did was they front they gave me upfront
money back then that's when they did it
they didn't do it anymore
and I got time you got the jam yeah and
I forgot how much I was it but I got
probably maybe like 150 grand yeah and
to shoot everything and I put almost
every dime well I put every dime on that
on the screen because we we shot it in
the Alex theater was all Union so was a
union crew we rent that everybody was
professional and was cool was when they
saw that when they came to the to the
show he was really proud he goes man you
know we do a lot of things with people
and we give him upfront money and then
also in the next meeting they're driving
a Hummer they're doing this and and
their project sucks he goes we saw all
the production that you put on it like
it was really good and he even told me
he goes when they aired when he aired
you know screened it to all the people
with Image Entertainment they gave him a
standing ovation because they saw it
first yeah and and he says it made me
feel good because it's my first project
with them so I just everything was
really good with that it just turned out
well it was on it was a target sold a
[ __ ] out of it like it would they had it
on the N shelves it was real good thing
I would literally go to Target and stand
by him people go by I would go to
Blockbuster videos it was there take
picture like it was fun take me home to
[Laughter]
Willie Barcena
writers demands well first Willie Willie
what was same thing he wanted points
like I want to get points on a globe
Willie first of all I'll give you points
that if we lose money you have then then
you have to give me money I already told
you that yeah and he's like no I'm like
okay well come on
I'll go look really everybody's getting
paid the same right favorite nations
every comics when it get paid the same
and people coming because it's it's
laughs up loser they're coming for the
event of it they're not coming for in
any one particular comedian
and I go the reason I want you and
everybody who cuz I knew everybody on
the I was only gonna shoot one I wasn't
gonna shoot Latin Kings comedy we did
four we did we for did for show show we
put it into one and but on this one I
only had enough money to shoot one show
so I knew it had to be guys that I knew
would kill the first time out solid yeah
because there's no takes you no no no to
takes or two shows and then so it was
really and it was you know and then I
had a couple of other possibilities and
then and that was the film - oh yeah -
be careful don't shout on video but it
but it was um it was in digital no I was
on it I hosted it and yeah so it was it
was fun man he was it was a really good
production then I did another production
with only fourteen thousand dollars
which was cattell trouble comedy slam
yeah yeah and it was I sold you read
read that came about because there was
another company called a Laguna and we
had a meeting about a movie that I
wanted to make and yeah yeah no no it
was just a regular movie I forgot what
it was but but the guy goes well you
know I really like that Latin Kaluza I
want to do something like that
I'm like the hardest thing I ever did in
my life because I'm thinking
everything's been done Latin version
comedy very I mean calm down ravenous so
I came I came up with a cholo comedy
slam and the yogi okay let's do that
all he had was for at least fourteen
thousand dollars now I mean like maybe
eight go okay let's do it
Mario your cholo yeah that's a loser was
you doing two things you're producing a
live event and you're producing a
production and it's just really a lot of
work when we got $150,000 it's easier to
do it half of the money winner dinner
$3,000 nobody I got screwed over I only
got 11 and we're gonna be without money
yeah I had to use my own partner at the
time and my girlfriend at the time who
was a producer was lisslow Hoff and she
helped me like it was literally her and
I for for a month and a half or two
months at a coffee bean with our
computers working on on everything you
know like trying to get just working on
the production meet having meetings with
people about you know quit man and what
kind of equipment we gonna have we got
over four hundred dollars just doing no
no we got we got a we got equipment for
free all the equipment was for free so
we saved on that but but you know the
crew had to be paid
we had an immediately laid no media did
get paid I think he got like I think I
paid like five hundred like I think
you've Lampa lose everybody god I think
it was 1,500 paid and it was five
hundred five he was bald at the time but
he but then when he did my shoulder he
wasn't bald I'm like dude you gotta
shave your head back wanted to would he
shaved in the restaurant anyway I wanted
George president but he was in jail at
the time there and I said listen can I
Rachel Ward in the letter said my bribe
is fifteen thousand that was one I've
done a lot of productions and that was
the hardest one ever has it was great
there was no money and he was so they
turned away and I'm not exaggerating
they turned away over 500 people police
had to come because the line went all
the way around was that it is the
million dollar theatre rule did you try
to take
yes you know that was part of that was
part of the idea I had but then the sky
his name what the hell's name I forgot
[ __ ] me over on that because where I'm
likely Ticketmaster now Mike I don't do
dick it Matthew
no no we do that Hitler bag then he kind
of he kind of [ __ ] me on that money
let's go [ __ ] him up I do want to [ __ ]
them up so I'm one time in a CBS master
and you never got the money towards a
lot of money I didn't get much yeah kick
his balls off there so that just shows
you manages when you when you when
you're not well you don't have the help
you need to do you can still do get
things done but they're just a lot
harder and you're gonna admit you're
gonna mess up here and there and you and
that's literally that whole production
the production the live production and
the whole production production was by
two people me and list and that's it
there were the only ones that did that
at the end I was [ __ ] exhausted I
needed like a vacation like three days
to [ __ ] just I was just out of it
yeah it was just hardest thing I've ever
done and it did well though it did well
Walmart further jumped me in so now you
have a new production coming yes
promoted yes please
this actually medina right maybe she was
$2.00 going down I'm doing this one with
a viewmaster doing a viewmaster I'm
putting it on a disc do you remember the
story I wasn't there but I remember with
I guess it was you and Willie were in
San Diego and there was some guys
beating up a gay guy jumped in and I
said Dan yeah I always [ __ ] remember
that to him like that was dope I always
tell that story to people even though I
wasn't there I loved that short Willie
Barcena and I got
another comedian rich something coming
company magic and they get we're just
walking bro and then like I see these
this punk rocker it wasn't those gay
punk right and he is banner beat his ass
dude like they're getting a good one man
and then like um another guy start
punching up his frezzer a bleeding from
his face mm-hmm and that was the [ __ ]
you know me I was jumped and even then I
didn't know who was who
but I chucked in man and I just saw that
guy about to hit him again and I just
jumped in and I just paused to go hard
in the face bro he has a [ __ ] good
story like that's a scene in the movie
then he fell down and started [ __ ] up
again and his print hit me in the back
of the head real hard
I went ahh and then this Asian dude
about to jump in - uh-huh but he thought
that I would beat up the gay guy and the
white dude were backing me up
oh my skin right here so then [ __ ]
Willy grab that Asian governor by the
teacher but he beat up beat up already
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] and the other two
just punches ass again bro man hits him
again knocks him out and then Willy he
like he grabs the other dude to the
ground but then he runs and when he
chases that foot but really weren't
wearing boots bro change that fool and
now pulls out that that other fool saw a
police car and he read his cyber and
locked the doors bro what up [ __ ] and
they were no arrests they were arrested
here bro will it fit through that fool
you got your ass kicked
each delay style
he was a referee an ambassador they had
to keep their two security guards there
there a manager and a black dude right a
black dude right he could take on those
two dudes by by himself metal too big
and my I hate when I hit the other dude
I hit him on the top of the head bro no
that's my [ __ ] it's two minutes to
get my stupid stuff it's world of good
but the next day man we went back to the
club they told who I was like it was
like free drink Willy got loaded go to
another bar no playing jazz with a bunch
of hipsters for the first time get to a
scene either give me hug these are the
best friends man oh and we went over
there brother Cheetos good bro drinking
there you go so look I've always been a
big fan I've always been a big [ __ ] hag
but so last year I went to s.a.w home
you [ __ ] show your Holstein
we did the construction guy you wound up
to remember that but could have [ __ ]
done a lot of [ __ ] no but last year our
goal for the project gonna do it now is
inspired I'll tell you how I was
inspired
last year I go to my sister's having a
birthday in Vegas so we go to a drag
queen brunch right which I was hilarious
it was great but I'm watching the show
right in the whole time and I'm hi I'm
Nev I'm drunk on mimosas but I'm the
whole time I'm watching these drag
queens dance I get into drag Appaloosa
they're like stars right now but in real
life their life must be sad really sad
and then I'm watching like these older
white men with a trump supporter looking
guys you know like with the girls on
their lap and everything I'm gonna go
they probably haven't doing all this but
in real life too but like that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you know what I mean so I
just started thinking about that so my
mind they go I'm gonna shoot a
documentary is too hard to do is too
much reproduction is gonna be too
expensive
Rocco I'll shoot a short film here we
got 2000 this time great no right now I
don't have any no I got a little bit so
then I did I wrote a script about a drag
queen that's you know an older drag
queen who's out of shape but she's
depressed and all of this and some
reason I've made it I wrote it and come
take place in the 80s so I wrote this
great script man I even send it to
Emilio Rivera and he looked at me say
bro I know I'm doing a good job so
anyway I wrote this thing and I figured
out how to I mean I can you know I think
I could shoot this with no money like I
do all my other [ __ ] but I'm like this
it's too good for me not to put some
effort into it so he started it no I
started the crowdfunding campaign and so
that's the girl I don't know yet and
that's gonna be a hard part to cast I
Rivera bro I don't know work with tides
a great guy funny guy but it's uh but I
think ty is actually you're too young
for the part too but that's a
transsexual is this someone who wants to
be transgender or is it someone who just
dresses in drag no the dress and drag
but they're also standard okay so you
don't live as a man it's it's because
it's in the 80s it's almost kind of like
the half trends like half man half woman
thing like like almost like you don't
like they want to but they don't know
how and so they kind of just sneak into
your biopic yes basically no no no so
it's a really deep story and then she
won't you know the character character
wants to commit suicide there so two
really dark any it's gonna be [ __ ] like
before Joker came out I was like I want
it to look like taxi driver I wanted to
feel like taxi driver and then when
Joker came out and I saw him like that's
exactly the look
looking for and me and my DP who's a
two-time Emmy Award winner we both you
know so joke and we're like that's it
Philips my guy Steven he's great he's
amazing he did my last name Glickman bro
he did he did the last one with me the
lesson which i want a bunch of awards
for and stuff
what Awards I won the People's Choice
Award for in Hollywood real Film
Festival and you were in a cable ace too
right no no I wish that'd be nice my one
award for lighting I won best short film
in Puerto Rico from Puerto Rico and that
was just that and then um and so it so
it's good you know and then I don't make
films to win awards but I want to win
awards so they people know that they're
good you know what I mean
and this is the kind of story especially
anytime you do anything about gays or
trans show what you're talking about
right now they always you know the just
the part where they're nice and happy
and well you know this one is round
nobody's happy in this one every it's
really the curtain just catch this
person's character is like like it's so
the presents went through so much [ __ ]
so much abuse and then there's someone
you go back home and you know no it's
just a character I invented in my head
and because and one of the things she
was like I remember one time I was on a
line at an amusement park and I saw this
this this woman who was obviously a man
like you did no makeup no long hair
dress nails shoes and I I'm like
everybody staring at her and I'm like
damn I just felt bad like I have a lot
of empathy and it was just like I feel
so bad for that person so I put all
those emotions like I'd literally I'm
gonna say that you guys are probably
laugh but while I was writing the script
I would cry there was a couple scenes
that I cried when I was writing because
when I write I don't know what I'm gonna
write I just write it as the character
and I was like oh [ __ ] that's so sad man
and I'm writing this [ __ ] okay oh I'm
tearing and I'm like in people like you
or a man went Starbucks okay
[Laughter]
that's why I wrote in eighties and so
anyway the thing is this I figured I did
a budget together in the film's gonna
probably cost me about fifteen thousand
dollars which is way out of my fear of
disease 15 yeah way out of my way no
it's actually and that's cheap that's
like still everybody working for almost
nothing so they're not a union
production lab so he's not even in
production but nobody's gonna be sag
it's gonna be sad but it's not but
that's the Union votes Mia but the
Gilbert no but the delay in for cruz
really good these are really good videos
on youtube people I love they have like
a good camera and good lighting like
good that one movie that they made I
haven't seen it but it was shot very
cheap about transvestite in Sunset great
movies yeah they shot with iPhones they
shot that look it looked way better now
right yeah okay it's grainy and like
some of the colors over I saw over what
do you call it
I saw a camera man cuz I was looking for
cameras and they're expensive
yeah I saw red camera for ten nineteen
thousand dollars a really good man
that's the one I saw right there talking
about and I and I saw like who the hell
uses these and I saw that everybody that
has a million views that every meme yeah
but you know what we can afford to buy
one of those and just rent it out to
people that's true sure it's on it run
it out to people you know people like
Joe another little small milk filmmakers
you bring it back
pay rid of camera well no I held my all
my own equipment what do you have
but I have I have a Canon c100 mark to
the idea yeah and then my DP owns two
Nikon so he those are decel DSLRs but
his are very it's a lot of more about
the lenses than anything so it just
depends so on this project I want to
rent the red if I can so you know the
thing is this if we don't get the money
or like right now we got about $1,200 if
we don't get the money we have about two
more months to go then it's just like
okay instead of renting camera now we're
gonna use this camera instead of doing
this we're gonna shoot that instead of
grilling you know doing a guerilla scene
in a city bus will actually rent the bus
so it those are the differences into
what makes a difference of the project
and you know I just man in the my thing
I'm like whoever gotta make this thing
happen Matador bro yes we're waving by
at the bus people leaving and then we
got inside thank you okay it's on is on
indiegogo the film is called Philly
delight and it's the light D - Li te
Philly like Philadelphia yeah the
characters from Philadelphia so Dan
Hurst her her name her stage name is
Philly delight and it's not it's it's on
IndieGoGo and you know we've got you
know every crowdfunding campaign has the
perks right you know your name and the
credits the script whatever but one of
the things we have on there for a few of
the spots is actually a speaking part in
the film an extra part in the film those
kind of things the t-shirts and hats and
all that stuff but yeah man so please
please give how can I find it if they
don't go to IndieGoGo because some
people are dumb they don't they don't
want to type in IndieGoGo and go search
for Philly delight so
your website yeah they can go to Joey
Medina calm and find it there are my
Instagram Instagram which is it's on
it's in my bio and Instagram at Joey
Medina comic and I and you know the
thing is this a lot of people one thing
I learned that a lot of people don't
like to donate because they're afraid
they're like I don't wanna I don't
really got the money on me right now
but they take they have an extra five
bucks so you have an extra dollar it
literally makes a difference if a
hundred people give a dollar that's $100
that'sthat's much so it really matters
you know what I mean and it doesn't I
don't care what how much it is you know
I want and if they can take that link
and you know share it give it to people
you know send it put it on their their
facebook or whatever that really helps
and you know because man it's it costs a
lot to make a film and this isn't a lot
$15,000 is nothing especially especially
when you're doing something that's a
period piece like in the 80s and 90s
because it's wardrobe does vehicles you
know how are you gonna control for that
in a small budget like that like it's
how I shoot it's gotta wait til the
street is empty - tree and you you get
two you get two or three cars and you
keep using those two or three cars it's
Philly delay the spine
you know then you know it's course even
more eco Christine now those things are
subconscious you know like props you
know you got your little phones you know
everything now you do things that are
subconscious on a light guy and you
shoot a different ways that's and that's
just the way it is so the more money you
have the easier that is the less money
you have the harder it is and then
you're like okay I can't have a vehicle
on this scene because I can't afford a
1980s car you know what I mean it just
it depends on that kind of thing that's
all production that's all but it but
that's the stuff that I really love
about filmmaking like directing and
producing is like producing to me is
directing but you're directing before
the production that's all it is and and
you just come up with ideas you probably
solve problems like all right how can I
do this how can I get there how can I do
this I there's a jail scene I already
got jail like a whole jail to use so I'm
like you know Sonia rules right can we
talk about where it is but it's it's
part of it's part of me over Museum and
one of the things that I have in the
museum is a whole jail and I know yeah
and and the thing is the guys you know
the guy knows me and I'm like dude can I
use shoot here things like yeah I'm like
[ __ ] awesome beautiful so we'll see so
yeah come on let's throw some 20s at
Joey go go calm guys go there to look up
Philly delight own you put my name
against me will come up or just put
Philly the light Joey Medina and you'll
see it and it's really gonna be a good
film but it's not I promise you it's not
gonna look like [ __ ] that that I can
guarantee it I never look like [ __ ] it's
like Mara's when they filmed it they
filmed it at a Kevin James Kevin James
Kevin Smith's work after hours at the at
the liquor store yeah there was no so
there's a I forgot the name of it
there's a movie they made in IKEA and
the people in IKEA didn't know they did
it like nonchalant like like I don't
know
I'm at Disneyland at all
you could you good boy you can't record
a black family fighting it was like when
I did when I shut my pilot shot I shot
at the Van Nuys flyaway like if it was
the airport and we did it nonchalant and
you know like it was a real Airport but
we had to do you know when you do
scurrilous [ __ ] like that does tricks
you learn you know like for instance I
had a shot where the Sun was behind the
building so that way we don't have to
use any any any you know diffusion and
stuff we shot on DSLRs so that way it
looked like we were just saying goodbye
to people like taking pictures in that
video you know we didn't have any boom
mic it was all laughs so it was you
planned that and you make it neat man
yeah so there was a security guard
watching us the entire time but they
never knew we were actually shooting
your scenes and like grease alone these
people oh yeah yeah basically I think
that's that was a security man if you
got money you can do it's just like food
I guess right you got a lot of food you
can make a beautiful thing of chicken
but you don't have a lot of food is like
you but now cuz I was poor just I liked
it like it was crunchy hello KTLA
building like a altri mundo you used to
know how to make the couple noodles but
turning into fettuccine in [ __ ] no I
don't know
no but I do remember you two a couple
Newton [ __ ] every [ __ ] night yeah
I promise to add to it yeah yeah bring
up the [ __ ] Kentucky me but but you
know [ __ ] bro how to get anywhere hear
that [ __ ] 3d map or I [ __ ] sat on
a rib
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah very rough email [ __ ] I've ever had
that that open you know that those story
about her on early time she would live
into you huh
yeah yeah yeah hop it hop it oh she did
I remember I didn't read it yeah she
lived with us and never yeah okay we're
a closet honey oh yeah it was we had a
one-bedroom but we rented everything
from a closet Wow then we had different
beds and then like poor Ralphie could
only like go in the living room so we
rented him the living room like it was
just everything to pay rent it was like
a wayward house for comedians the first
barbecue Ralphie had was in your
apartment huh I think so I don't
remember yeah but I think so I know we
had one Merriman's at first but it was
like but but but Rafi was always really
lucky like one time I remember he drove
me to I did an independent movie I was
in it I wasn't doing behind it a cap and
he got the part and but then he would
meet he would make food for everybody he
knew how to cook real well and you know
so Rafi was always lucky he was always
stepping in the right place so he's
showing up to the right place you know
but um but like a lot of people even
though we let him stay there they didn't
pay but they would stay there like
everyone's were staying at her apartment
everybody if it wasn't for a day was for
forever you know what I mean or they
rent it or not rent it but everybody
will stay at our place was in Hollywood
yeah yeah I was right right across tree
from paramount oh [ __ ] okay no Clinton
huh was it hood back then no no no it's
nice oh yeah there's actually real nice
let's argue about ya parking was really
bad I had a boot up my [ __ ] car once
no I guess it goes my [ __ ] car was
more expensive it's gonna be good on
that car bro would do buy coffee at
daughters and I had the big old big old
cup and I put it in the thing and then
he moved the whole thing full of your
car no ok I do remember that the putt on
the floor I'll post it by Taylor
floating bro
oh [ __ ] that's right I came up with an
idea I had an idea to do a video for
like a self defense for people like
Chinese to video bro you know I don't
get a hug like a preacher now or
something
in a so called I made a married woman
would thank you
yeah we talked about a lot of stuff man
would let that was the winner oh [ __ ]
Jesse wants to do the podcast look
glorious yeah what happened to Luke man
living in Texas
avoiding child support I don't know come
out here Luke huh you work with him
right you got a lot of people in our lay
into the comic strip huh yeah you know
how to get in like really and cuz I
booked it yeah Gabriel's first road gig
who actually Gables first road gig
I gave him both it was a one-nighter it
was in Tucson that one I wanted
opportunity well did he
that sure was Gabriel Italian Dante and
Joe Diaz oh wow okay yeah all right cuz
I should book that show and then I
booked him in El Paso to open in El Paso
that was his first real Comedy Club Road
gig so yeah I don't think he remembers
that but no no but yeah but that was
that was really cool but I remember the
first time I saw a gamer was the first
time you saw gay bro unite together we
were Gotham Gotham's Gotham's and he was
all they're doing he was you know doing
his little thing we were like all right
we were talking to him I remember that
man like yesterday was funny and then
last week he was doing two sunbro look
they were Janey yes because they needed
somebody go there really cheap
yeah no no no fifty he got 50 bucks
between flight at plus a plane flight
and that's a two though I think the
budget was like I think 200,000 special
was show because it normally was two
comedian they brought three this time
yeah yeah yeah man without hotel man it
was like a golf course that used to be
the best golf course there in 1950 over
here
Randolf park or something like that it
was across from Randolph Park so it was
a Double Tree Hotel yeah okay good thing
so yeah no but it was cool
but pretty garlics huh big oh yes yes
like six foot four yeah in the the
giggles called Bugsy's Bugsy's yeah
Bugsy [ __ ] alright - son yeah - son he
knows [ __ ] man who sent who's on it was
good yeah but gable killed it he did
great he went over there and um and then
Gabriel and I one time did a gig in um
where is it [ __ ] we drove to Lake
Havasu I wanted you in Lake Havasu yeah
yeah we did that gig was a weird bar
right 50 bucks
long drive we were there with Jay was
there with his girlfriend bro at the
time she would like that she worked for
the television in Santa Barbara or
somewhere oh that's right sandy look at
the back seat back seat you look at them
whatever the hell it has all the way
there does I am romantic I thought would
be the word roll me too like we got
engaged
what happened that someone paid $10,000
for [ __ ] statues oh yeah she's crazy
I did a chick I think every guy's
attracted to crazy girl somehow but it's
like yeah I always married weird sheiks
updated weird chicks and like now I'm
just like all right whatever
and II was the one yeah for the back
seat as you drove out of the world with
her like a soldier it's any customer
she's beautiful I was 13 even broke up
going to London Bridge member yeah
everybody's the one where she was in
newscast and I had a joke it was like
something every time we had sex I'd say
dis just in
[Laughter]
but she was cool man she had a nice job
she was on television and you know no
remember what time she took me she took
me uh check cash huh yeah she took me to
her banaue fitters and she bought me a
whole wardrobe no I wore that wardrobe
every [ __ ] day how's her boyfriend
she just fizzled out no what happened
was family didn't like me because you're
Puerto Rican no no because I was a
comedian she was Colombian and the funny
thing is before she dated me she dated
Bill Murr Bill Maher and but like I
don't know it wasn't really serious but
she dated him for a little bit so I'm
thinking [ __ ] she dated this guy he's
also successful and I'm you know I'm
[ __ ] doing [ __ ] Gotham's and [ __ ]
but she was really cool and we had a
great time and then it just it kind of
just died out or whatever but her family
didn't like me at all her family her
brother was a lawyer everybody in her
family was successful and you know I
[ __ ] if you may really early high well
I married three times
yeah the first one you marry either way
but you Stewart does with his kids yeah
yeah of course yeah and then my second
but the last one I think is the one you
you guys was from LA and that was her
name was Marie and she all those tattoos
I don't I think she was a statue yeah
she was [ __ ] beautiful
[ __ ] but crazy earlier right yeah yeah
now crazy just like weird man like I'm
thinking like I'd literally the day we
got married or the day before we got
married I was like I gotta that's right
so I want you to [ __ ] come to this I
want your best crying oh that's right a
big dinner
yeah we saw boxing brother after day
it's my friend bill my friend
my prim no more oh but we all gave us a
part with a big-ass dinner and there was
a [ __ ] foot right boo could the Chow
maybe was no no no it wasn't we go where
they had to Club the House of Blues
oh yes and that's food all the seats
broad it had a ring without three map or
matches yeah yeah yeah that's right it
was faster yeah but their marriage won't
stick went to [ __ ] man last year we got
we actually got divorced because of 9/11
oh this is what happened 9/11 happens
right no no we were living in the valley
and um all of a sudden she wakes me up
and my mom's on the phone and I grabbed
the phone and my mom was crying like
someone in my family died so as my mom
I'm trying to pay attention what my mom
is saying I mean all I'm thinking my
okay I got a flight get a get money how
to buy a ticket got to go to New York
that's all I kept on thinking and then
finally if I figured it out my mom's
talking about a plane you crash like no
mom I'm okay cuz she thought maybe I was
in one of those planes some weird reason
so I hang up the phone I put on the TV
and I'm watching it I'm like oh my god
and that was just there what Paul
Rodriguez two weeks before we were in
the World Trade Center two days before
it happened we were doing a show and um
so I'm watching it and then I'm watching
these people holding hands jumping off
oh my god I never seen that and then I
remember looking up at my wife at time I
go you know life is [ __ ] too short
I'm out by that Friday I filed for
divorce cuz I'm like I don't want to be
unhappy I'm like these are already
unhappy yeah I was already unhappy she
was nuts sheet read Wow excuse me she
was literally bipolar this was before
bipolar became was thinking of Fame
famous or whatever but she was bipolar
she was a lot of crazy [ __ ] out
there she's really no no my girlfriend
by says no she's bipolar
it was a Tuesday I was in like radar
yeah we found a file for divorce and one
year it was like literally we were
together brought here that is so funny
man like not funny but yeah that you saw
that we could remember the owner of the
laptop yeah his wife and him are
watching that movie with Ben's bar and
then Kevin McCann Eric Matthew
McConaughey to lunch
yeah just Jessica Parker I think yeah
yeah watch your fingers do lunch and
then she paused it it should or a ham on
a divorce [ __ ] but I can see that
because that movies kind of like that
what's over that movie don't watch it
yeah they're best friends into the end
any man she probably not doing here
he'll do big boy stereo not bad but you
know the funny thing is and it's like I
don't know if folks are unaware like in
your blood like this is this yeah you
felt about that before yeah before she
she was just really crazy one time one
of the things that happened between her
and I was she we got into a big argument
literally just an argument she was
probably as close to me as you are right
and she gets picks up the [ __ ] phone
calls 9-1-1 and I what the [ __ ] I see
you and I say cuz I really know what's
gonna happen that she's gonna come rest
your ass that's just witnessed yeah so I
walked over to Starbucks I was there I
waited for about an hour and a half or
three domestic palooza yes
I came back in from her purse I could
see there's like could you know official
police paper sticking out I'm reading it
like this it says that I hate her so I
go I go why did you tell the police I
hate you she was well I didn't tell him
he told me I'm like what are you talking
about now she would always go to tanning
beds right so you know when you tan is
you've got you your skin peels so she's
like oh he saw this and he said and I'm
like [ __ ] blind no I know so I said
what'd he do so then she I go why didn't
you tell him I didn't I know what
happened she's a really [ __ ]
beautiful girl the cop was like okay of
course so they did so I waited to the
next day the next day I call the police
department and I said want to speak to
the detective in charge so I know how it
works it's good you know they're gonna
they're gonna file this job yep and it
so I speak to the detective I go hey
listen don't explain it well you know
the officer said this I go I know I'm
reading the report ago but is there any
picture she was no I go why not he was
well do you know you don't have to make
if there's an injury you show pictures
and go there's no injury she's heard
skin is peeling from tanning she's
peeling all over not just where he you
know her arm heals well you know
literally nothing probably gonna happen
from this and I'm like yeah of course
now you know but I was like dude man
this is [ __ ] it's wrong so anyway
that died but but after that I'm like I
can't I can't even here so I even talked
to her like hey I was just like I'm
gonna void he hurt at any any any
possible moment I can but I'm talking to
this chick and then you know shortly
after that 911 happened I'm like [ __ ]
this I'm out and magic she need to get
put in a full nelson bro yeah no yes she
was just nuts to make you happy huh bro
yeah she was crazy
swing on you fool she ever she hit me a
couple times and they after be like wow
I would pretend hurt more than it did
your parents when they hit you don't
want to use she will play it off like
that's sad
what's up shows coming up beside yes yes
yes I'm going to be going to San Antonio
I think that's I think the 2713 every
weekend at jokesters so those new club
over there jokesters and then I'm gonna
be New Year's Eve and then the week
after New Year's Eve I'm gonna be the El
Paso comic strip I'm in Sao Paulo with
you who did DeRay Davis oh yeah that's
great we're gonna be this weekend we'll
be in Portland
December 13 at the Revolution Hall and
I'm gonna be in Tijuana Mexico at the
ante what but they got a pop al so much
Wendy Santa Ynez California Chumash
casino Victorville California holiday in
Victorville Deborah 22 is gonna be all
in Spanish no doubt Wow
December 27th or 31st Phoenix Arizona we
have a show December 27 28 29 no show 30
and 31st and then we have zero improv
January 2nd to the fifth planet tail
[ __ ] Tommy T hey buddy 12 Tijuana Mexico
bodega again ooh
January 22nd Santa Cruz at the catalyst
judge when you pair Pasadena ice house
26 like Spanish or and then and then I'm
taping filming my my
Netflix Netflix special in English
January 27 at the Santa Ana California
Observatory Theatre Early Show in
English second show in English also 28
general 20a time doing the Spanish
version of that show or in espanol a bit
your children to ever be there two shows
and also Oklahoma City a new club called
Bricktown comedy club spin up in a
couple of months January April 2 9
through 12
[Laughter]
even before about we have my show
whenever that enjoyable book me actually
I'm gonna cancel Willie Barcena
cancelled you wanted to tequila bottles
well you know the thing is like when ASA
Help book El Paso it was fun because you
know you try to book your friends and
stuff and but if I ever booked another
club again it'll be anonymous like oh
they'll be a anonymous email everybody
their mom's gonna hate you yeah yeah it
goes fool you know
edibles yeah there you go thank you
help me sleep they help me sleep alright
that sketch I took myself to a hospital
once with edibles here's that sketch
you
yeah what's up fool joy Medina follow
him on Instagram Jordan aware join me
Joey Medina comic on Instagram and that
album we were talking about your first
album we're going to find it at Amazon
yeah yeah it's called about below the
belt and everybody album and they're
ported all your friends are my ex-wife
is the girl and the in that album the
little [ __ ] was a friend of mine at
the time and I think there was a couple
of people in the background what's up
Martin Rizal in the DZ yeah man let it
make you man thank you guys